Speaker 1: We have been, man, this is this
is really bad.
We have been talking about how.
The modern, reactionary movement, I don't
call them conservative.
There's nothing conservative about them, the
modern, reactionary Trumpian movement is dangerous,
and we learned that.
When they kidnaped, the governor of Michigan,
attempted to kidnap the governor of Michigan,
sorry correction, we learned that when they
did all the things they did on January six,
these these are dangerous people and there
is a man who posted videos to Ticktalk showing
himself hunting for quote non binaries non
binaries, by which I imagine he meant people
who identify from a gender standpoint as non-binary
or transgender.
That's my understanding of what this guy meant.
Tick Tock has removed the videos, but it's
been widely downloaded and we have it and
we are going to look at the video and it is
going to be disturbing, not because there's
any gory images or anything like that, but
it's disturbing because it is another reminder
of how dangerous these people are.
This man shows himself carrying out what he
calls a snipe hunt, demanding non-binary is
be turned over to him.
OK.
And he says if he finds people meeting his
criteria, he will load them into the back
of his vehicle, transport them, presumably
against their will, which we would call kidnaping.
He doesn't say they're going to want to come
with me, and he would bring them to a hospital
for treatment.
This would be very illegal.
Let's take a look at the first video as if
we need like the extra details.
He's wearing an F. Joe Biden hoodie in the
video as well.
Take a look at this.
The man, I guess, goes by the handle steel
Walker, 40, to live and believes he's doing
the Lord's work.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: This may come off a little transphobia,
but it's not.
It's not like I'm doing the Lord's work.
I'm trying to help people.
I'm here to get all the nonbinary, so I'm
at the Motel six right now.
We're starting here and we're going to do
all the non-binary is picked up, put in the
back of my truck.
We're going to take them to a hospital.
If you have any more binders here, I'm shutting
this mother.
I'm shutting this whole operation down here.
Any non-binary, anything ready to go, sir.
We're going to get all the non-binary.
Let's go.
I need to get them back anyway.
All right.
We're going to get all the non-binary right
now.
If you see a little binary, snatch him up
if you got any non-binary.
I got to pick up and I got to take.
You don't need somebody.
I need to see where the non-binary.
I don't understand where they're hot, camouflaged.
You got their binary can flow.
Are there any non-binary in this hotel?
Because it because it's there.
That's a problem right there.
We got some let me out to get him.
Speaker 1: He's asking about.
Where the non-binary.
This is terrorism.
This is terrorism, you know, I stopped short
the other day of saying certain things.
We were looking at our terrorism because I'm
not sure this is terrorism.
This is going out there and saying, based
on your membership in a group, the group would
be trans non-binary.
I guess everything that falls under that umbrella.
This guy doesn't like and saying, we're going
to round you up and we're going to take you
in.
Now he's not saying we're going to kill you.
He seems to at least have the common sense
to know that would be even more too far.
So he says, we're going to take you to treatment
at a hospital.
This guy has previously posted videos encouraging
others to quote go hunting and implied that
those who identify as non-binary should be
shot.
Here's the second video.
Speaker 3: Then, if you want to go hunting.
Get out.
Get out into the deep woods and you can.
You see a lone non-binary is running around
everywhere.
Just jaw jacking, indoctrinating everything
the wildlife.
Catch them house
Speaker 1: bomb.
So.
Good for Ticktalk for pulling it down.
This is not free speech, free speech, you're
threatening crimes here.
A number of different crimes.
That's number one.
But this is scary.
The I can't even imagine if I was trans or
non-binary or had anything other than what
this guy sees as the acceptable identity traits,
I would be scared, I would be scared.
And to be perfectly frank, we were talking
about this on our live stream over the weekend.
I don't know if the solution would be to flood
the red states with progressives to sort of
like push these people out or at least make
them not want to go out and do the stuff?
Or is the solution to get the progressive
the hell out of these places and get people
who are LGBTQ plus out of these places for
their own safety?
I don't know.
I don't know the solution, but this is extraordinarily
disturbing, and it is difficult to think as
someone who's not part of these groups.
It's really difficult for me to imagine the
terror that folks must be going through when
guys like that are around.
Hopefully, police are investigating.
I don't know for sure I will find out and
let you know we'll have these clips.
If you're only listening today and you have
a sort of morbid curiosity about what the
guy looks like and what he's doing.
We'll have these clips up on our Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.
We'll take a very quick break and be
right back.